well james took a totally different
approach the high arcing missed
never seen that before
he gets a great bounce
and if he could have gotten it cleanly
he would have had a look
i agree with what you said white howard
or deandre jordan into the ball game for
rebounding purposes but it worked out
for the lakers unfortunately ran out of
time and how about the hustle by steve
kerr getting out of the way
so james
unable to hit the three free throws
porter did an excellent job tipping it
away from the basket
and steph curry and the warriors
survived
meanwhile klay thompson in his 14th game
back
with an absolute gem 33 points he's with
lisa
clay i just asked you how you feel you
said i feel great just what got into you
what got into you in that fourth quarter
[Applause]
that was fun and
i i saw a couple go down and
you know
no matter how many i miss i'm always
gonna feel confident i'm gonna make the
next one
what did it feel like for you
to get that hot again
oh man it's
it's everything you know i mean
last two seasons were weird
i'm not good at watching and
it's inspiring honestly to keep going
keep working because
i'm still not even playing starter
minutes so
keep working 14th game back like you
said after missing two and a half years
what was the weight like just to get
back to where we're used to
i'm not gonna lie it was hard there was
a lot of hard days
a lot of days on the shuttle board a lot
of days in the squat rack but my
goodness it makes it worth it
our fans are incredible i mean we saw
those last three free throws they're
loud can't hear nobody in
man it's just uh it felt amazing we
missed you too welcome back
[Music]
well the joy that the game gives him is
evident every time he plays
for a little extra special after what he
went through in those two and a half
years those two devastating injuries
and a magnificent performance tonight
for klay thompson
[Music]
nba sunday showcase tomorrow presented
by reese's on abc the hawks and celtics
from boston coverage tips off with nba
countdown at 1 30 eastern
and 10 30 pacific
final score from the chase center the
warriors 117
and the lakers 115